[Music]
Christian
welcome welcome everyone I'm johnine
and we're so glad that you showed up
early today I know it's a big day for
everybody so thank you for coming our
normal time will be 5: PM next week so
be sure that you don't get used to this
early time
zone and also Ash Wednesday is coming up
this Wednesday on the 14th her saxi
right here has invited us to join them
for Ash Wednesday and they're starting
that with a 6:30 pancake dinner and then
a 700 p.m Service uh both of those will
be in the Family Life Center which is
the big building behind this
building uh also for next Sunday uh
February the 18th we are going to be
having the state of the table meeting
and everyone is welcome to come here
updates on everything from the ministry
teams to finance so we hope to see you
all there and
now if you'll just take a deep
breath
relax release all the cares and worries
of the
day we'll bring ourselves
to our creator thank you so much for
giving us this beautiful
space for giv us the hearts for your
ministry allowing us to be
still allowing us to come before your
presence and to worship
you
we're just in the back room praying and
uh
you know one thing led to the other I'm
sorry we're a bit behind today in in
every way our team is so appreciate you
guys waiting for us not that you had a
choice in the
matter all right do you guys want to
stand with us and we're going to get
started actually with a new song um it's
called good God which we were joking
about earlier because it kind of sounded
like hey let's do good God you know what
I mean it sounds like an exclamation
it's actually the title of the song
because God is good and he is gracious
and we're celebrating that together
tonight
so let's jump
[Music]
in 2 3 4
1 Be Still My
Soul Be Still My
Soul be still my soul my God is
here be still my soul Be Still My Soul
be still and know that my God is here
all that I need to know is this you are
a good God the fer of Heaven calls me
you are a good god her heart beats in my
chest you are a good God and all that I
have to do is rest you are a good
[Music]
God I won't be
afraid I won't be afraid I won't be
afraid I won't be afraid my God is
here he will make a way he will make a
way he will make a way my God is here I
need to know is this you are a good God
the maker of heaven calls me his you are
a good God and your heart beats in my
chest you are a good God all that I have
to do is to are a good
[Music]
God all right we're going to sing you
gave me your
eyes you gave me your eyes you gave me
your heart your spirit fls through my ve
you gave me your eyes you gave me your
heart your spirit flows through my ve
heart your spirit flows through my veins
you gave me your eyes you gave me your
so you gave me your eyes you gave me
your heart you had a plan right from the
start and I know who I am cuz I know who
you are you are a good God all that I
need to know is this you are a good God
the maker of heaven calls me him you are
a good god oh all that I need to know is
this you are a good God and the maker of
heaven calls me H you are a good
God
know God Of Heaven
[Music]
you are a good God you are a good God
you are a good God you are a good
God all right I want to dismiss the kids
to go to their classrooms and if you
guys would walk towards the doors your
teachers are going to lead the way to
your classroom so please wait for them
to give you
instruction and you kiddos please do me
a favor and love on your teachers
tonight give them lots of thank yous
because they do such a great job of
making space and being intentional about
y'all's time together so y'all love on
them give them a lot of
[Music]
gratitude all right as they're making
their way out we're going to transition
into uh prayers of the people so most of
you guys guys know how this goes but if
this is your first time let's read this
prayer aloud together and then we'll
leave a little bit of space for you guys
to um speak out loud something that
you're carrying into this space
something that's heavy on your heart
whether that's a name of someone that
you want to pray for a situation that's
going on and then we'll wrap up the
prayer together as well and if you're
watching online um we're so glad you're
with us you can leave your prayer
requests in the comments
there Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
those experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
[Music]
you
for the names in the moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light healing and
hope peace and a deep sense of your
presence
amen
[Music]
e
can I
respond to the love that you have
laish
on
me how can I
[Music]
respond to the love that you
have
on
[Music]
me let's repeat that how can I
respond to the love that you have
lavished
on
me how can I
respond to the love that you have
lavished
on
me I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for
[Music]
you
every part of me and every part of
me who wants to love you like you love
me
Lord and every part of
me who wants to love you like you love
me my
Lord
I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats free I have a heart
that beats for you I have a heart that
beats for you I have a heart that beats
for you I have a heart that beats for
you I have a heart that beats for you
and I have a life I'll give to you I
have a life I'll give to you I have a
life I'll give to you I have a life I'll
give to you I have a heart that beats
for you I have a heart heart that beats
for you I have a heart that beats for
you I have a heart that beats for you I
have a life I'll give to you I have a
life I'll give to you I have a life I'll
give to you I have a life I'll give to
you I don't have much
I don't have much but I have heart that
beats for you I have a heart that beats
for you I don't have
much I don't have much but I have a
heart that beats for you I have a heart
that beats for
you
[Music]
just encourage you guys in this next
song talking going down which is
something that I don't feel like we're
myself especially not great at doing um
and I just encourage you if you would
like to open your hands um As we sing
this and just encourage Jesus to um to
make himself present with you he is here
but for us to tune in for us to make
ourselves re receptive to his Spirit to
his goodness when we can so often Rush
ahead busy
ourselves fill our
schedules run the race right now let's
just have a moment where we let him
speak to us where we let him show us his
[Music]
love oh good shepher would you take
teach me how to
rest I'm rushing on will you make me to
lie
down will you
build By the Waters that
refresh will you call my name and Lead
Me safely
out
for my
anxious to lab on
and from the rest chist that has put my
mind
asleep will you call me back and gently
Slow Me
Down Will you show me now what to lose
and what to keep
oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me Down
[Music]
when
my with only GRE and
gold and my grasping hands are afraid
you won't
provide will you P the wi the loosens of
My
[Music]
Hope set your table here with what truly
satisfies oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good sheer
oh
God me
down slow me
[Music]
down it's okay on the busy Streets On
The Busy streets make
myself
work nothing
I would you Le me home to the PES of
your if the house is yours I'm sting at
your
feet oh good
sheer oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepher oh
good Slow Me
Down Slow Me Slow Me Down Slow Me
Down Slow Me
[Music]
J so God thank you that you're not the
one who busies us you're not the one who
rushes us and pushes us but that you're
gentle that you're
patient that you're
gracious
thank you for making space for taking
your time with
us we want to take our time with you
God we want to invite you
in into the busyness and the
chaos and we want to listen to your
spirit when you're telling us to take a
breath to let go to
surrender so tune our hearts to
you help us to be
sensitive help us to make space for
[Music]
others we love you
God and we we want you with
us in Jesus name we
pray
amen thank you guys will all turn to the
people around you say hello get to know
them really quickly or make them feel at
home and then Brett will get us started
with the
message well Grace and
peace it is so good to be with you all
and uh look at you you Faithful ones
here on Super Bowl Sunday go
Cowboys all right I stole that joke from
Gary Miner that's what he said when I
got here he was like go Cowboys was like
I'm gonna I'm gonna take that oh I know
us tortured Cowboy fans but I know we
have at least one San Francisco fan here
might be some other I don't know um but
anyway yeah I'm really really glad to to
be with you and um just to yeah to
welcome you into this space uh that is
true of course for all of us but um as
always that includes those join us
online
and um anyone here tonight who is new um
thank you for just for being here I know
uh what it can be like to walk through
those doors for the first time and uh
especially when you don't have like a
group of five or seven people around you
you know that makes it easier but it's
it can be really challenging when it's
just you um so all that to say thank you
um thank you for being here I hope you
feel that sense of welcome so um we are
in right now the uh the season uh in the
church calendar called the season of
epiphany so um basically the the time of
Advent that kind of leads up to
Christmas um whereas Epiphany is like
the season after Christmas so if Advent
is kind of you know preparing our heart
and mind to receive Christ well the
season of epiphany is you can kind of
even hear in the name it's like oh my
gosh it's happened what now you know
it's kind of a unpacking like okay um
Christ is being born in me so to speak
um the the spirit has been given now
what you know so that's that's kind of
what the season of epiphany it's a lot
of passages around like kind of a
revelation a revealing God is with you
God is in you you know it's it's those
kind of very um I don't know you can see
it in my hands I'm trying to communicate
it's like it's that kind of season may I
don't have words it's this you know um
It's that kind of season so we'll be
coming into lint next week that's a
different kind of season
good in its own way I think we actually
we need some spaces at times to kind of
quiet down reflect uh actually that last
song was kind of in that in that Spirit
um so anyway um but right now it's still
still Epiphany and uh really yeah
beautiful in its own way so this is um
technically Transfiguration Sunday big
word we'll get into that um so that's
our passage so the title of my message
is caterpillars and
butterflies and um our text is uh Mark
chapter 9 verse
2-9 says after 6 days Jesus Took Peter
James and John with him and led them up
a high mountain where they were all
alone and there he was transfigured
before them his clothes became dazzling
white whiter than anyone in the world
could bleach them and there appeared
before them Elijah and Moses who were
talking with Jesus Peter said to Jesus
Rabbi it is good for us to be here let
us put up three shelters one for you and
one for Moses and one for Elijah
parenthesis he did not know what to say
they were so
frightened I love this he's just saying
words you ever feel the need to do that
I kind of did that tonight um when we it
was silent you know I mean just oh God
fill the space you know and that's um
that's kind of what he's you know just
doing that um then a cloud appeared and
covered them and a voice came from the
cloud
this is my son whom I love is that
beautiful whom I love like of all the
things he could have said I mean he
could have just skipped his second part
listen to him I think that's often our
image of God this is my son listen to
him you know that's sort of how we
imagine God the Father you H but it's
this is my son whom I love what a
tender heart there this is my son whom I
love listen to him suddenly when they
looked around they no longer saw anyone
with them except Jesus as they were
coming down the mountain Jesus gave them
orders not to tell anyone what they had
seen until the son of man had risen from
the
dead so obviously this is uh this is a
whole this is kind of a moment you know
this is a moment where um Christ kind of
like his his humanness so to speak is
like pulled back a bit and um and his
his divinity his his glory his his
Beauty um shines forth right that's the
Epiphany kind of season it it it
radiates out from him he is um
unveiled and this you know this this
Glory this beauty um it it's like in
this moment it kind of shines it becomes
very obvious on the
outside but the truth is um if you kind
of know the story of Christ um it was
there all along we'll get to this kind
of later in the message where it's not
like something is being added to Jesus
right now like where he's like just some
guy and then the father's like okay I'm
going to really give you my glory now
and he like gives him some glory and
then Jesus like wow look at me you know
um no what the idea is it's it's always
there within and then In This Moment
unveiling Transfiguration revealing what
is
true uh but but that's but it's been
true of him all along and it's been
evident um in his words in his um
wisdom in the Miracles he's done in um
his tremendous
compassion in his patience his
listening um his utter surrender on the
cross his glorification in
Resurrection and even his availability
to all people in um his Ascension like
it's it's it's it's been true it will be
true and it's true right now in this
moment so it's kind of all there um
however here's kind of the question
driving the message
tonight okay so that's true for
Jesus what does that mean for us exactly
I could imagine maybe one kind of
reading this text would be a a kind of
you know uh Jesus is so
awesome good for him you know it's kind
of like great um but but what what does
this mean for for us as um the community
uh of of Christ and
um I think this is actually a question
that the New Testament as a whole is
really interested in but I think our
English translations have tended to kind
of um obscure that fact and so I want to
read just verse two again of Mark 9 UM
and then we'll get to some other texts
so it says after six days uh Jesus Took
Peter James and John with him LED them
up a high mountain where they were all
alone and there he was
metamorph before them that's the the
coin Greek word the original language
there
metamorph now a natural question would
be like well that that's an interesting
word you know is that found anywhere
else in the New Testament and um the
answer to that is yes of course it's
mentioned in the other tellings of this
exact story like in the other gospels um
Luke and such but
besides that is it mentioned anywhere
else two places it's mentioned um the
first is in Romans 12
12:2 where Paul writes to the
church and he says this do not conform
to the pattern of this world but be what
metamorph by the renewing of your
mind then you will be able to test and
approve what God's will is his good his
pleasing and perfect
will uh then we have another mention
this is 2 Corinthians chapter 3: 18 and
you can even hear in the language a
little kind of Nod to I think that
moment that we just read in Mark about
the Transfiguration um he says this and
we all again writing to the church and
we all who with unveiled faces in other
words
uncovered unveiled faces contemplate the
Lord's Glory we are being
metamorph just a slight verb tense
difference
metamorph into his image with ever
increasing Glory which comes from the
Lord who
is the
spirit so I think this is can can you
kind of see the connection that we're
drawing here this is um I think a really
profound
Insight that it's in essence the
transfigure I mean this really this is
quite a statement it might even sound in
ways sort of borderline
heretical um even though it's I mean
it's right there in the New Testament um
and as we'll get get to it's it got sort
of Lost in Western Christianity but it's
always been there from the earliest days
um that the truth is that the
Transfiguration of Christ isn't just
about Jesus like wow look at him shining
like the sun
incredible uh what's the truth that
these texts are getting at what are they
inviting us into the the invitation
there is that we are invited into the
great
Transfiguration let me say that again we
me you are invited into the great
Transfiguration we are invited into the
great we might call it the great
metamorphosis could you kind of hear it
in the Greek there metamorpha the root
word is metamorpho which trans um uh
transliterated English is where we get
metamorphosis and which is a fantastic
word you know when I think of like
Metamorphosis I think of something like
um more than a subtle or incremental
change you know I mean when you say like
that wow look at that that there like a
metamorphosis it's not like subtle I
mean thinking for example um like if
there was like a duck and then the duck
grew up I don't really think of that as
like a metamorphosis you know I mean
it's sort of like oh look it's a duck it
used to be so tiny and now it's like a
bigger duck you know it's like stronger
it's a little um but it's you know I
mean and and it's at the cellular level
it is profound you know I mean it's
something but just on the outside it's
not necessarily like my gosh wouldn't
even recognize you you know it's just
you know still quacks just duck uh but
that's different than like say the um
the way a caterpillar of course is like
the classic right caterpillar becomes a
butterfly that's one of those like oh my
God you know what I mean like you see
the
caterpillar just I mean they're they're
cute in their own way I guess you know
just kind
of I mean just slow has like oh poor
little fella um and then it goes in that
cocoon and then it comes out I mean
that's like right that's a
metamorphosis where it it was innal long
and now it's like operating in another
dimension I mean literally like it all
it knew was on a little twig and
suddenly it is soaring through the sky
like what like you you might um and you
might be surprised like I can't I can't
believe that's happen like how did that
thing become that thing um but here's
what's interesting that it's not as
though it became a utterly different
thing though like it's not like you know
a new species you know it's it didn't
become something it never was that's
what's so amazing about that that little
caterpillar is like that it it had the
capacity by God's grace and a little bit
of its own struggle you know the whole
cocoon story and kind of it's got to
fight out of there you know um to what
to be
transfigured to
be metamorph to to like to the point
that you're just like shocked you know
like in essence it had the capacity to
become something you never would have
guessed in a million years it had the
capacity to become and and so what I'm
continuing tonight is that when I look
at each and every single one of
you who I
see are
people who by God's grace this isn't
just of you know pull yourself up by try
roll hard spiritually you know and it's
not just about that um it is it is by
God's grace um and your own yes to
Christ that's a part of it um I'm
looking at people who have the
capacity to become something you never
would have dreamed in a million years
you could
become and I'm believing this is a word
for someone here tonight who maybe right
now you're just feeling very caterpillar
is you know just like inching along like
oh this change feels extremely
incremental if if there's any change at
all you know um
but but by the spirit God just keeps
breathing on us keeps welcoming us keeps
inviting us keeps calling us to the more
that he has for
us and and I think this is where
um kind of Western Christianity in ways
has gotten a little I don't know I it
feels like we've kind of lost the plot
we've lost the vision you know when I
think of what so many Christians and
churches um I mean you could say all
over the world but we'll I'll just stick
with the West kind of like in in Western
culture uh it's almost like the vision
of like you know if you ask the question
like why are we
here you know it's a fair question like
what are what are we doing and it's it's
almost it's really a question about um
what we call Telos like aim end goal
purpose like you know where are we going
and I think for so many of us and I'll
just speak for myself like kind of
growing up in church settings it was
sort of like where are we headed well
I'm I'm I'm trying to be better um but
in essence I was like trying to become a
like stronger Little Bit Stronger
caterpillar you know what I mean like
okay like I want to be like Jesus and so
I'm I'm I'm trying to be good and so
what is discipleship and um following
Christ what's it all about you know
trying hard to be good to be a good
Christian and not a bad person you know
some something along those lines which
um to be clear I'm not kind of putting
that down like that's sure you like
that's a great start um but but can you
hear how it's sort of missing like the
more that God has like that's not
necessarily a
metamorphosis that's a you know it's
sort of like I used to be a little duck
and now I'm like trying to be a little
bit bigger you know a little stronger
duck uh and I think you know I think our
imaginations have been sort of limited
in this way and that that that
limitation it's even reflected in the
translation of the Bible that we were
reading um because of course Mark 9 uh
verse two uses that word
Transfiguration but if you read it um
Romans 12 and you read 2 Corinthians 3
in your English Bibles it doesn't say
you're being invited you know into the
but be trans transfigured by the
renewing of your mind so it's like a
shout out back to Mark 9 and it's like
no no no no no no no no no it is but be
transformed be transformed 2 Corinthians
3 trans
transformed and I think it was sort of
like a it's like a subtle way almost of
being like hey hey hey hey hey don't you
forget like like in essence
um you're just caterpillars you know
you're just little ducks so don't start
getting any ideas about kind of who you
could become you know what I mean it's
there's almost a a kind of subtle
limiting and
um I think even our language at times of
imitating Jesus following Jesus is while
it's good at another way another level
it can kind of I think limit us um in a
sense because it kind of is almost like
a call to be a stronger caterpillar um
but have you ever met met
someone and you could just kind of sense
that this transfiguring process had
begun in them like it was like they were
it was like a different like we're
playing one game and they're playing
another
one um I had this uh experience this was
years ago like seven years ago um and
it's been a few years since I told the
story so I'll tell it again uh and I was
at my daughter's uh class Park party
this is back when she was she was young
enough to have class parties now she's a
freshman high school but this is you
know I don't know second third grade or
something and uh so they would invite
parents like go and so I go and we're I
just get there and I'm you know meeting
the parents or whatever and cleaning up
cupcake crumbs and just doing the class
party thing um but there's like this guy
off to the side he looks older I found
out later he's the grandfather of one of
the kids there
and it was like the weirdest experience
like I kept sort of
awkwardly like looking at him just kind
of like um I was just there was
something about this guy I was like what
is going on with him who who is he and
he wasn't even doing anything like you
know life of the party it wasn't
anything like he was if anything like
quieter than everyone it was strange I
just kept looking over at him I was
getting this Vibe and it was like a good
vibe though not bad vibes like maybe in
the same way it's almost like the
opposite of bad VI like you know where
you pick up on someone they're not doing
anything but you're just like oh gosh
you know what I mean like it was almost
the reverse of that I was like this guy
is freaking awesome I don't know who who
is this like and then I started I go
over I introduce myself start talking
with him and I'm like oh my God it just
confirmed it I was like I want I I was
like tempted right there to be like can
you Mentor me I don't even know who you
are I'm just can you I feel like you
have
something I don't you know good
preaching kale yes you have something I
don't like I needed it was
remarkable and I remember I had a
conversation with Maggie my wife
afterwards and I was like that guy and
she's like I know that guy right and I
was like yes oh so long story short we
end up um I get to know that man's uh
daughter and it turns out like the thing
I'd suspect like I didn't know is this
guy spiritual or really you know
whatever and um turns out yes he's a
retired Methodist Minister and I was
like gosh darn it I knew it I knew it I
knew something was going on with you man
and I didn't tell him that um and I
actually was talking with his his
daughter um and about him and it was
interesting like you know if anyone
knows someone or kid you know kids no
and she was like it was you could tell
even she was struggling for words but
she was like yeah yeah my dad is um he's
like he's a really good man you know and
I was like yeah you know you're not
kidding like there was it was like magic
like um what was going on
there I think that gentleman like all of
us had been
invited into the great
Transfiguration and he was saying yes at
some very profound levels
doesn't mean he's perfect you
know what I love about that is this was
an obscure man he's not famous in the
Methodist world you know you know just
pastored a few
churches and he I met him at a Class
party in Wy like who knew there Saints
just walking around Wy
Texas like it just the most Ren you know
that's what's interesting about the
Transfiguration process which again we
we'll kind of touch on um in a moment
like it's it's not necessarily some
outward you know like this moment right
it was the great unveiling so Jesus
shines but clearly as Christ went down
from the mountain even though he was
still transfigured so to speak right
still filled with God Spirit still
radiating Divinity and yet it was kind
of veiled hidden you know
um isn't it beautiful that we're all
like invited into this process in
essence we're not just
caterpillars um we're called to be
butterflies there's a quote this is from
the Eastern Orthodox Theologian kalistos
wear this language again this will be
probably a little uncomfortable for us
we've been kind of raised in the western
kind of Roman Catholicism and
protestantism is kind of Western
Christianity and there's Eastern
Orthodox um which is like Greek Orthodox
and Russian Orthodox and there's sort of
a different wing of the church they use
language like this they like to talk
about Transfiguration a lot we you know
we are more kind of caterpillar thinking
you know um so if it makes you
uncomfortable that's okay you you'll get
you'll get used to it over time so
kalistos wear a theologian in that
tradition says this God's Incarnation
right so Christ becoming human opens the
way to Humanity's
deification to be deified is more
specifically to be crustified the Divine
likeness that we are called to attain is
the likeness of Christ it is through
Jesus the God man that we are and you
can see he's kind of grasping for words
here we are are in goded divinized made
sharers in the divine nature that's a
quote from second Peter 1:4 share I mean
that's strong language right sharers in
the divine
nature maybe one way to think of it um
is that like if God is the son we ar
necessarily at least probably other
religious Traditions would want to say
we like literally are the son you know
or not literally but you know what I
mean the metaphor like we are God or
we're in that kind of a capital G way
Eastern Christianity it would it would
lessen a little bit it would say oh
maybe we're like raised you know we're
made in the image of God we are
partakers in the divine nature so it's
not that we're like if Christ is the
second person in the chinney it's not
like I'm the I'm the fourth you know
it's it's more like
um we are in deepest Union with our
source The God Who is Love The God Who
is father son
Spirit to kind of sum it up I would say
the call of the Christian Life um it's
an invitation to divinization it's to be
transfigured as Christ was
transfigured um now I'm opening up like
a lot of cans of worms and uh so you
might have questions that's fine you can
kick me an email later we can talk later
something um but I want to offer three
kind of quick clarifying points in
closing just to give I don't know put
some meat on these bones so to speak so
I don't just leave you kind of like with
this big idea like what divinized well
have a good week you know um so let me
let me try to I don't know flesh this
out a little bit um since I've had more
time to you know to reflect on this um
so number one Transfiguration is not
adding something an experience a miracle
more of God um but it's actually it's an
unveiling and you might say it's like a
stripping away of what clouds our true
nature you can see that in the story of
Christ right again it wasn't that he
wasn't this and then in that moment the
spirit fell upon him and he like became
you know no no it was a revealing of
what was already there um similarly for
us um this isn't about like how like oh
man I pray that one day I can have the
Transfiguration
experience like oh wow just like that
guy that retired Methodist Minister like
whatever oh I I hope that I can have
that you know too bad too bad until then
I guess I'll just just keep my fingers
crossed you know just I know somay I'll
become a butterfly right no I'm just
caterpillar you no no uh the idea is we
already are
this it's just um it's kind of clouded
over so to speak this is why I think at
our best um this is why we can in a
healthy way want to move away from sin
you know because again it's not about
like sort of a heavy-handed stop sing
you know it's more like oh my gosh these
things are are holding down my butterfly
essence you know my who God's called me
to be and I want a source I want to be
free you know I mean that's sort of the
the heart it's an unveiling a revealing
of who you already are which is
different right then boy I hope you can
get there some people have gotten there
and if you try real hard you can get
there can you hear how this is different
this is like you you already are there
you know you already are there you say
but why am I not experiencing it well
that's the growing into the revealing
right of of what's there like maybe one
way to think of this is um for kind of
we often will use language like Lord
give me peace oh give me your peace you
know and that's a I've used it before I
continue to use it but can you see that
actually like you might say that um
Peace is actually like your
nature like peace is just who you are in
your essence like it's just
but the experience of peace is when
angst and anxiety in fear do
what and then suddenly you're like oh my
god oh thank you Jesus right it's like
oh my gosh peace and then we but we
might get confused it's like oh Lord
thank you you have given me your peace
you know what I mean but it's almost as
though I there was this thing I didn't
have called peace but now oh now I've
I've got it all you know I mean no no
it's it's like already there it's just
as things like lift right similar idea
where to be you're already transfigured
you're you're in Christ you know um but
it's it's got to be revealed all right
second um this will be quicker you will
be the last to know how your
Transfiguration process is going maybe
that's disappointing to you like darn
you know I wanted to have a moment where
I was like praying and then all of a
sudden like I'm glowing
is happening oh my God I'm going to text
my friend you would believe it I have a
Transfiguration over here um no it's not
it's not like that uh in fact I say
you'll be the last to note because I
mean other people will tune into it you
will um you will lag behind have you
ever noticed this this these changes
like you know you start to notice like
huh I haven't had that fearful thought
in like three
months huh that like
level of anxiety still some anxiety it's
like not the same that it used to be you
know what I mean like it's this and you
start tuning in later you're like oh my
gosh I think often um the people around
us start to notice it they tune into it
but for you um it will lag behind so
that's I think it's also relief like
don't worry about it don't Focus don't
obsess on it don't compare you know well
how transfigured am I compared to
someone they like no no no no that's
like don't don't don't go there um
you'll be the last to know third and
finally um Transfiguration is not
otherworldly um but it's actually bodily
and even
political um this is a really a key
point because I think everything I've
said th far I don't know it could make
it sound like you know um I don't know
we're just you know we're here at the
table we're just about things of the
spirit you know and
Transfiguration and it's just like you
know um but as opposed to but then you
know that's different than the muck and
mire of real life you know what I mean
like the messiness of of an election
year and politics and the social and the
public and it's sort of like oh ooh
gross you know we don't want to bring
that we don't want to suly this place
with that muck and my like no no no no
no no no no Transfiguration it's deeply
bodily um it's not about floating off
into space and just like it's like it
actually Roots You grounds you right
here right now
now like you are present and showing up
I Think Jesus was like the most embodied
present person ever and you see it in
his life like went to the Cross um some
folks didn't like what he was doing in
this world like in Practical tangible
ways um I'll close with with this this
is a quote um from Theologian Maggie
Ross U who's really helped me I should
gave her credit she's really helped me
think through so many of these themes
and um even so much of this
Transfiguration stuff she says this
Archbishop Desmond 22 um who you might
know he fought um apartheid in South
Africa for many years wonderful
wonderful I think it was Anglican um
Church leader so Archbishop Desmond 22
repeatedly reminds his audiences that
contemplative prayer is so subversive
that if governments understood what it
is they would ban it those who have
entered the process of transfigured
perception you want more on that you can
look up Maggie Ross transfigured
perception you I won't go into it don't
but just it's key Turner phrase
transfigured perception invariably
become
controversial for it is not possible to
coopt them into the service of one power
group or another by employing the usual
coercive tactics and what are those oh
we're so familiar with them of flattery
or fear Envy or
desire such people will thus be free to
make true and considered political
choices that
can and usually do go against the grain
of mass
opinion these choices are usually costly
because they expose lies deceptions and
hypocrisy can you see where this like
this starts to touch ground um in real
real
life as
Church may we all may we all enter in
huh may we all enter into the great
Transfiguration in the name of the
Father the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen so uh as we come to the table of
the Lord tonight as we take take in the
body of Christ in the bread the Christ
in the wine may it be a holy moment may
it be a moment where we say oh Lord
everything that's that's holding me back
from this transfiguring process may it
just like fall away and uh may I be
transfigured into the image of your son
Jesus May that deep work be started in
me so um the way we're going to do this
tonight is we will just go row by row we
start here at the front we'll work our
way back um we'll form kind of one line
right here in the middle um there's
going to be one person with bread and
two people um with the cup so that way
you can kind of split off and you can
kind of go around to you know get back
to your your section and your your seat
um we do ask you kind of come here and
then like go around as opposed to going
right back into the lon Zone um you
should know uh that the red is wine the
white is grape juice uh we practice with
it's called an Open Table meaning if
you're here tonight and you want to
participate do it there's no one like
you know no theological police like are
you part of our denomination you know or
whatever um just you're you're welcome
to to
participate and uh and finally you can
partake Whenever However you'd like some
folks like to kind of kneel here um you
can leave your cup right there uh or you
can return to your seat and partake
partake there there are trash cans kind
of scattered around that you can put
your cup in when you're done so this is
the table
not of the church but of the Lord It's
Made ready for those who love him and
for those who want to love him more so
come you who have much Faith you who
have little you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long you
who have tried to follow and you who
have failed come come because it's the
Lord Jesus himself who invites you and
it's his will that that those who want
to meet him should meet him here come to
the
[Music]
table
am
[Music]
we're going to close out with a song um
called me the peace and um I appreciate
Brett's message of just kind of like the
encouragement that uh that there's
always that invitation to continue to
change to be
transformed to keep growing and um and I
just feel like sometimes we can be hard
on ourselves or I can be hard on myself
for the areas where I haven't changed
yet or where I want to change but I just
received this song tonight as kind of
this voice of God like you know what
peace be with you like I'll continue to
do the
work carry my peace I'll do my thing you
have
peace so let's continue to invite him in
and uh you guys are welcome to sing this
song along with us if you'd like to
stand and sing it as kind of a prayer
over your week um over each other even
um or if you'd like to just sit back and
soak this in you're welcome to do so
Gary's going to lead it for us
[Music]
May the peace of the Lord go with
you may the PE peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace of the Lord go with
you
wherever you may
go May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace of the Lord go with
you you May the peace of the Lord go
with
you
wherever you may
go if he said
you to the
Wilderness may he give you
flowing
spring through the long day
of your
[Music]
exence taste the
sweetness man
bra May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace the Lord go with
you
wherever you may
go if he send
you on the Raging
Sea may his Mercy go
before to show
you where you calling lead and protect
you in the
St if he sends
you through the veil of Tears may he
join you as you
we he hold
you when you meet your fears in the
shads
dark May the peace of the Lord go with
you May the peace of the Lord go with
you
wherever you may
[Music]
go
again thank you so much for joining us
this
evening if you guys are new there's a
little table right over here to your
right and on that little table there's a
card that we'd love to have you fill out
so that we can get in contact with you
and welcome you and answer any questions
that you may
have uh my name is johnine and so if you
need any support in any way a prayer a
hug someone to talk to uh find me after
the service I'll be happy to uh to meet
with
you so here at the table we're committed
to creating an inclusive Christ centered
community that touches lives and gener
generosity is a key component of that
mission if you'd like to join us in
supporting the work financially you can
scan the QR code on the screen or out in
the lobby you can go to the website at
theable tx.org and if you
prefer you
can um that's supposed to be
me uh my wife and our regular givers so
I'd like to invite you to uh join us in
that and now if you'd like to
stand and receive a blessing I'd like to
send you out this week with this
blessing that's been written especially
for
you you are a child of
God you are a child of God this is true
on your best day and it's true on your
worst day so as you go out into your
week ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved that you are worthy
that you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone that you come in contact with
be
blessed have a great week and we hope to
see you back here and next Sunday
remember it will be at 5:00 p.m. and
following that will be the state of the
table so the Peace of the Lord be with
you wherever you may
go
[Music]
for